d I walk out to a new 15 minute game
neither three plate so big choice okay
I'll go for some Kings Indian style set
up let's start with G 60 so why does not
really interested in a sharp game right
with III one positive feature about down
delaying Knight f6 is that you actually
have the chance to play something like
that transposing into a Dutch opening
mmm yeah what's what's the best setup
the typical way to play this is of
course going to Queenie eight Queenie a
to prepare you five
guy has set up is some a bit uncommon
against the Leningrad Dutch but not not
so sure how how bad it really is it's
not very promising as much as clear but
is it really bad it still looks like
healthy development ok very L earlier d
hive yeah not quite sure what to do you
can go if I've and let him capture on e6
I can think about plants like c6 night a
62 c 5 as well a5 96,000 and many many
ideas yeah in 5d takes e6 some is
probably not especially dangerous for
black but it also is ok for wide let's
try to activate the night first one idea
is not to c5 and then after later 'if
I've and capture only six the Apostle
capture I can take with the night also
it's not clear i can go to c5 i can
create c6 and c6 and 97
yeah a six and such a slow move I'm very
tempted to attack ascender I'm not
threatening really to take on d5 he's
got Bishop c4 at the end so it could if
you want I can just cancel it's not a
big deal
yeah I still expect just 93 taking on c6
some gal maybe can maybe take on c6 but
it shouldn't be really critical there
are sometimes ideas to take on c6 and
played b4 and b5 but this is usually
with the bishop on g2 with the bishop on
d3 in general it's not particularly well
placed the only idea is the bishop on d3
to get in a quickie form so he realized
that i'm not really threatening to take
ok let's let's do this put more pressure
on d5
hmm no is taking not quite sure why but
i retake okay night to d2 yeah probably
really wants to play for my only five
new fear which looks nice at first
checking the centers may be answered by
C five but I can still play you for
right 5c five
okay what else is down 92 is so again
somewhat strange move c5 can also place
you five but then probably you form 15
c-5m I'm very not sure about this before
what whoa okay if he gets the shock i FG
five and takes a play 95 but then he
doesn't have a check a little loose
piece ok so maybe is still be five if
you cannot go see five only five then it
is simply a good move yeah if it's not
working then it's a miscalculation what
can I do oh this this I didn't expect at
all but this is probably my mistake it
is at least a move that you need to
think think of
yeah there's a multitude of good good
ideas now f 4 mm f4 he might play c5
this could could backfire I could also
play c5 here he's not threatening much
taking I just retake with the porn and
it's not not much going on c5 though he
can maybe play before and attack it
immediately it's not so damned if I want
dad I can also consider to take on e4
and play Bishop to g4 but this man I
don't like that really 96 so maybe 96 a
move covering yeah maybe 96 intending 95
all night f4 if he takes on f5 our plane
data for with the temple tomorrow this
has the advantage of preventing c5c 45
as I can now take with the the night but
it doesn't make the pawn structure so
static compared to play see 65 for
example it takes on f5 I just plain idea
for and win the tempo and then take next
move in fact this looks of Braha taking
on a five okay just the retreat
yeah it's um you need to think about
them captures only form by now because
it's got such a shaky the supposition
looks look shaky to me fe 4 94 94 Bishop
four and then lie to see if I for
example it takes e4 and threatens Bishop
g4 this would make a nice use of the
dynamic features of the position
yeah it's not easy to decide also
because um it's very likely that move
like f4 is simply good for black he's
got yeah he's got before NC 5 this is
really a possible call to play but hmm f
4 B 4 C 5 what's not clear at all I'm
unsure if I should take really okay what
I don't like about taking is that it
actually gives white tonight on night on
d to some sense in this position here
this night is just need your chickpeas
the only thing that I can do is see five
maybe he can play c5 actually okay no
his playing is playing rather quickly
okay let's let's go ahead yeah the night
on e six is really a great piece that
covered also g5 so now
John do I want to prepare it or go
immediately forward with the with the g
4g phone takes takes takes on g4 Tech's
on d4 Knight takes Queen on g4 at the
end and this really looks like a
complete complete disaster like should
have something in fact I have the
discovery 94 but he can drop all the way
back to d1 take on c2 and then play f3
ah looks looks terrible
yeah this is it's terrible let's go
ahead
yeah my calculations takes takes Knight
takes Knight takes Queen takes Knight to
deform I must take now there's simply no
alternative oh wait wait wait wait I can
I can oh no it's check let's check on f6
I was just briefly considering playing
that D for you but it makes no sense
okay let's take him and after Queen
tanks g4 I actually have a choice my my
plan was not deform attacking the Queen
and the bishop here so he needs to go
back all the way to d1 and then just
night XE to Queen take c to f 3 with the
idea Queen g6 f3 after G 326 h3
immediately wins and night xf3 you can
you can sex the exchange on f3 look at
three GF and Bishop h3 threatening Queen
g6 checkmate and on the King move Queen
to the H file and this is disastrous
cannot believe maybe there's something
better but this was my initial idea and
I'm playing this now here maybe a there
there are other ways to go about it like
f3 for example 3 here but this is really
it must be strong really
yeah the point is we should night takes
a three ripped xf3 checking the exchange
g3 it's just queen / queen age 583 or
something g3 is the worst possible way
to defend it but I'm threatening Queen
g6 so it's not it's not evident what
what what should go yes so taking on g2
or queen g6 or Bishop g4 I mean this is
a pretty good choice
hmm
so Queen g6 it just takes with the night
and it's not the parentage of how to
punish all this of course he has also
the move Bishop h3 which looks very
fleshy and after taking Queen g6 is made
but he can play Knight takes a three on
Bishop age three okay maybe maybe I can
take g2 even Queen g6 check yeah it
doesn't look it doesn't look down look
viable and of course I can just take it
and it's not bad but or going to and
Queen to h5 also not not bad if I take
and I think he needs to take what the
King ready do I have a good move Queen
g6 that squeegees free it doesn't really
help much
or just Bishop g4 you cannot take on
these six because of Ruby aid okay come
on I'll just play Bishop g4 him intended
Queen to h5 I don't really want to take
on g2 it somehow helps them maybe
there's a direct technical reputation
but here I don't I just don't see what
white is moving just night xf3 I
wouldn't save the day I can just take it
on f3 g3 is complete nonsense Queen
takes d6 I can fly rook the eighth and
it's ridiculous to take this 496 cannot
do that I don't see means this looks a
very dangerous
yeah sometimes in those positions and if
you if you check this with an engine you
are surprised what kind of absolutely
correct positions still armed playable
sometimes out as far as far out as
possible okay Queen to h5 you know this
is the way to go King we cannot run with
the king is just queen h1 mate and I'm
just piling up now night xf3 now rook
takes a 3s third is the strongest
here a very simple continuation as rook
f6 to h6 and um no move it takes with
the pole on a three at just bishop h3 or
look at three again but maybe bishop
h3h3 years even stronger I don't know
I'm out of ideas I think white white can
resign with the clear conscience CM if
he wants to he simply got them look on a
one Bishop be to work on b1 and they
don't contribute to the defense at all
this is a bit term bit too much
yeah in general um after these g6 Bishop
g7 setups for black where you don't have
9 f 6 plate though sweet porn openings
like this year this color set up or
Bishop f4 and so on they lose not of its
attractiveness if black can still move
the f porn so a transposition here to a
Dutch it's really a good good
alternative even if you always play the
Kings Indian this is a good idea to make
it even more a symmetrical deposition so
this was rook f3m my intention the only
question is is there something better
even rook f3 takes Bishop takes curtains
immediately but drew Carey my plague
Queen takes d6 yeah but okay what what
is what is it actually doing I can just
play rook f8 if everything else fails so
this is probably just the best move
yeah you can go Queen Queen d6 or
something to continue and I don't really
see a direct meet after that but Queen
d6 I can just go look a to f 82 to
threaten f2 maybe
yeah 26 km there really is nothing else
yeah one funny a motif would be rook h3
takes bishop f3 in fact this in lots of
cases it's probably really winning not
sure the way if you would it's a good
idea to calculate such fancy stuff if
you can win went down simple moves as
well so let's just go here and see how
he intends to protect the f pawn will
get one as some not so great in terms of
giving giving the king some some air
yeah I don't really see another move
besides look everyone I feel you cannot
allow group takes f 2
uh-huh today will look something that's
of course always possible I didn't
really pay to pay too much attention but
isn't this mate how does it prevent made
now I overlooked actually this Queenie 6
check from before but it doesn't it
doesn't change matters simply no way to
protect h1 now
yeah mate into awesome oh yeah made into
probably kept like when Jade or queen h3
or something but it's it is a maid
gaap you can enter the proof it is yeah
maybe you can it's no way this wouldn't
be good okay now he lets the clock run
down bit late
maybe he saw some ghosts and is asking
yourself what why am I in this position
and
white resigns
okay yeah he wrote a message to me he
wrote the first 15-minute game I lose to
an opponent whereas a plan if chess was
more like that bardock would not be my
main game I'm not quite sure what bar
Lucas maybe someone can can tell me in
the in the comments here on YouTube yeah
pretty pretty solid win it's really a
good idea if you know beforehand I mean
I didn't know before but sometimes it's
a good idea of you normally play the
Kings Indian for example and you know
the opponent is going for four moves
like III and so on or like this then d6
intending a quickie five on on f5 setup
is a good idea delaying this night this
is much more enterprising than having
the knight on f6 already so on so we saw
in the game with this quick f5 I got an
active position rather quickly and he
have got a good very good central
control the key point was that he cannot
I think playing c5 because of a form and
this winds winds upon and a piece sorry
it wins a piece of course walking he has
got one or two points but it's it's good
for me so and after this this looks very
nice now actually taking once was very
interesting alternative let's let's just
have a look something like this for
example and I've got this pin Yakama ng
this this is interesting it's of course
a problem that the tanks but yea it is
was an interesting way to go but this is
certainly also interesting he should
probably play before and c5 at all costs
in fact after after
before I was intending to play this move
i'm not i'm not quite sure if this is
correct maybe maybe I can play gphi
first but this it's tricky it's tricky
g4 on that edge for so complex complex
battle the only thing that's clear this
was already very very tricky g-form and
now we've got I think the exact line
coming he cannot accept a poll on g4 he
must take but this is just drowning in
two and two the game here the computer
gives f3 also with a big advantage but I
don't think this should be much of a
difference yeah this is also plus two
according to the computer for black here
Bishop g4 yeah I'm found the radwells
queen age five also here Andrew k3 so
yeah it looks like I found them the most
forcing way to win this yeah thanks for
watching this game